we're told to look at the coordinate
grid above I put it on the side here
identify one system of two lines that
has a single solution then identify one
system of two lines that does not have
that does not have a solution so let's
do the first part first so a single
solution single single solution and they
say identify one system but we can see
here actually there's actually going to
be two systems that have a single
solution and we talk about a single
solution we're talking about a single x
and y value that will satisfy both
equations in the system so if we look
right here at the points of intersection
this point right there that satisfies
this equation y is equal to zero point 1
X plus 1 and it also satisfies the well
this blue line but the graph that that
line represents y is equal to 4x plus 10
so this dot right here that point
represents the solution to both of these
or I guess another way to think about it
it represents a x and y value that
satisfy both of these constraints so one
system that has one solution is the
system that has y is equal to 0.1 X plus
one and then this blue line right here
which is y is equal to 4x plus 10 now
they only want us to identify one system
of two lines it has a single solution
we've already done that but just so you
see it there's actually another system
here so this is one system right here or
another system would be the green line
and this red line this point of
intersection right here once again that
represents an x and y value that
satisfies both the equation y is equal
to 0.1 X plus 1 so Y is equal to 0.1 X
plus 1 and this point right here
satisfies the equation y is equal to 4x
minus 6 y is equal to 4x minus 6 so if
you look at this system there's one
solution because there's one point of
intersection of these two equations or
these two lines
and this system also has one solution
because it has one point of intersection
now the second part of the problem they
say identify one system of two lines
that does not have a single solution or
does not have a solution so no solution
no solution so in order for there to be
no solution that means that the two
constraints don't overlap that there's
no point that is common to both
equations or there's no there's no pair
of XY values that's common to both
equations and that's the case of the two
parallel lines here this blue line in
this green line because they never
intersect
there is no coordinate on the coordinate
plane that satisfies both equations so
there's no X&Y that satisfy both so the
second part of the question a system
that has no solution is y is equal to 4x
plus 10 and then the other one is y is
equal to Y is equal to 4x minus 6 and
notice they have the exact same slope
they have the exact same slope and there
are two different lines they have
different intercepts so they never ever
intersect and that's why they have no
solutions